ul de champlain sera ouvert aux
automobilistes en direction de montréal
une ouverture officielle donc a dû être
retardée de six mois elle devait avoir
lieu en décembre
c'est donc demain le grand jour est pour
en parler on joint le ministre fédéral
de l'infrastructure et des collectivités
françois philippe champagne bonjour
monsieur champagne bonjour madame
bourbonnais donc en fait on y arrivant
enfin le fait on est fébrile en effet
brees pour les mots real et on est
fébrile pour les travailleurs les
travailleuses
on va justement aller faire la dernière
inspection le cet après midi comme vous
voyez derrière moi alors très fébrile
cinglant jo pour les gens qui ont
attendu on parle de plus de quatre ans
mais on s'est donné une infrastructure
moderne qui fera la signature je passe
de montréal pour les 125 prochaines
années alors on est très très fébrile et
surtout moi je pense à tous ces héros là
les plus de 2000 travailleurs et
travailleuses qui 24 heures sur 24 sept
jours par semaine
beau temps mauvais temps parce qu'on eu
des journées qui était pas mal plus fois
qu'aujourd'hui oui ces gens là ont dû
être à l'oeuvre pour nous donner s'être
grand pont la loi qui va enjamber le
saint-laurent alors très fiers d'aller
les saluer une dernière fois aujourd'hui
bon et vous serez dans la première
voiture toute première voiture qui va
traverser le pont demain à 5h tout à
fait hybride rechargeable ça sera la
première voiture qui marquera l'histoire
parce que je pense qu'on est rendu
l'offre comme société et on va traverser
vous savez le français bel de champlain
c'est aussi grand que la piste
d'atterrissage à l'aéroport trudeau le
mot est aussi haut que celui du stade
d'olympie c'est vraiment une oeuvre
majestueuse qu'on s'est donné c'est
grâce au génie québécois l' expertise
québécoise aux travailleurs et aux
travailleuses de chez nous je pense que
chacun de nous un morceau de cette
réalisation la dans le cas et ça tombe
bien c'est le 24 c'est la fête des
québécois et québécoises alors célébrons
ensemble et on aura beaucoup à célébrer
aujourd'hui et demain évidemment
donc on se tourne vers l'avenir mais
vous tenait aussi à ce qu est ce qu on
se souvienne de l'ancien pont qu'on ne
l'oublient pas bah effectivement je me
suis inspiré un peu dur et line vous
savez on avait voulu imaginer peut-être
un parc urbain mais ça devenait trop
compliqué au niveau de l'ingénierie
c'est au niveau de santé-sécurité ce
n'était pas possible
par contre ce que j'ai dit on essaie de
s'inspirer d'événements historiques et
de dire
montréal et aux montréalaises aux
québécois québec parce qu'ils voudraient
un morceau de cette infrastructure là
qui a été avec nous pendant les
dernières décennies
si les gens veulent en morceaux en
français évidemment dans toute la santé
sécurité
on va permettre aux gens de d'en prendre
un petit morceau comme ça on se
rappellera de ce grand pont là champlain
qui nous a servi pendant plus de 65 ans
je voulais vraiment le peu concon on
déconstruit ce pont là et qu'on en parle
plus mais plutôt que cette grande revue
la passe à l'histoire
et maintenant on pourra même faire
participer les gens lui reçu plusieurs
messages aujourd'hui des gens sont
enthousiastes
alors tant mieux on fait ça ensemble et
ça fera semblant laisser les gens
veulent un morceau en soit là pour en
donner un donc devenir vous ne vous
n'allez pas les vendre l'homme ça allait
donner les morceaux du pont oui on va
les données évidemment ça devrait être
fait avec l'entrepreneur avec toutes les
normes de santé sécurité vous savez on
déconstruit pas en 2019 comme on le
faisait à l'époque
alors tout ça ça sera fait avec le
développement durable on s'assurera
donner des choses qui est que les gens
puissent apporter à la maison mais c'est
quasiment une façon de redonner aux
montréalais et montréalaises 7ème roller
passent aussi à l'histoire alors on
s'inspire des grands moments
on essaie d'en faire vivre d'autres de
montréal et au moral est bon donc des
morceaux de béton mais l'acier par
exemple pourrait-il être recyclé je vous
lance une idée
monsieur champagne peut-être sourire est
là et toutes les idées avec laquelle ils
sont bienvenues en bourbonnais oui tout
est possible on verra évidemment que ça
soit fait comme je vous disais avec
toutes les normes de santé sécurité les
normes environnementales applicables
mais on va le faire de façon responsable
respectueuse de l'environnement est
certainement toutes les idées sont
bonnes je prends votre idée 1 en direct
nettement puis certainement va la
considérer oui avec l'acier on pourrait
peut-être skela l'acier puis pique ça
serve la construction de veau d'or par
exemple aux entrées des ponts du pont de
deux entrées du thon ce serait
magnifique mâle en bourbonnais
c'est génial et on dirait que je vous
dis oui on va le regarder
c'est une des idées qui vient tant mieux
on est prêt à tout on regarde et on veut
vraiment que les gens puissent avoir un
morceau et puis si les gens peuvent le
recycler si les gens peuvent en donner
une nouvelle vie
on parle beaucoup de 2 de prendre ces
matériaux la de lire
cycle et de faire ça intelligemment moi
je suis tout à fait ouvert à regarder
votre proposition
bon mais tant mieux alors il faut penser
à la démolition vous le disiez on parle
de 2 à 3 ans ou moins 400 millions de
dollars donc ça va être compliqué là où
vous devez faire un appel à vous avez la
wii la déconstruction vous savez on a
une oeuvre au dessus du fleuve saint
laurent n'ont qu'une voie maritime
actifs au dessus de l'eau en hauteur
tout ça c'est très très complexe c'est
pour ça qu'on disait que ça demandera de
trois ans d'expertisé
comme je vous disais aussi parce qu'on
entend recycler les matériaux on entend
faire ça aussi dans le cadre du
développement durable donc là on
applique les meilleures méthodes les
meilleures technologies de la meilleure
expertise qu'on peut trouver pour le
faire de façon intelligente et c'est là
où on va trouver les bons entrepreneurs
pour nous aider à faire ce travail là
bon alors vous verture demain en
direction de montréal et puis le 1er
juillet en direction de la rive-sud et
là on aura vraiment accès à notre
nouveau pont je remercie beaucoup
monsieur champagne te fais merci les
bourbonnais on va suivre ça a percé au
revoir